Rachel's in Texas hey Rachel welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave it's a
blessing to be here talking to you
you too how can I help well my husband
and I were very stupid six months ago
well a couple months ago we weren't
gifted with a $30,000 get out of debt
money and we got out of our debt and and
paid off our $24,000 vehicle and we were
going to stay in the vehicle and save
for buying houses the vehicle started
not being what we wanted anymore so my
husband and I decided to buy a truck and
we put another loan and now we're 21,000
in card debt and 6,000 and personal debt
and we are renting a house for 1325 and
our lease is almost up and we are
looking to buy a house again
to get another loan but the good things
are we didn't know about Dave Ramsey
show until now we know what we're doing
with our money we've learned our
spending habits and we've corrected them
where we've got our emergency fund we're
ready to start the the snowball of debt
to get out of debt but we're not sure if
this is a smart idea to move into a to
buy a home but our goal is to have a
home that is less rent than we're paying
now or equal because we are dead and you
don't need to buy a house when you're in
debt yeah you're gonna say that yeah you
did
so did we just stay in the river also
truck worth um well we bought it for 21
it's a I don't know the worst Kelley
Blue Book or how long have you had it I
mean since October and what's your
household income I said well it was 77
and
and I just got a job for the first time
in three years and I'm gonna be bringing
home I think it'll put up to 81 so what
do you owe on the stupid truck 21 where
did the money go from the car that you
had there was $20,000 um like our
monthly bill where did it go
no I mean you you took $30,000 and you
paid off a $24,000 car and then you
bought a $21,000 truck is what you told
me right the rest of the 30 went into
our personal debt where did the money go
from a sale of the $20,000 paid for car
we kept it where is it
we just we trade oh we traded it in
good job sorry so you bought a $40,000
pickup okay stop in trouble with your
math okay you have at some point in this
story you told me you had a $24,000 car
that you paid off with a gift and you
have paid for $24,000 car was that
correct yes how in the world did you
trade that for a $21,000 truck with a
$21,000 loan where'd the $20,000 go from
the paid for car um I'm not sure I feel
like that the the Viet we were given
$7,000 from the dealership to trade in
the vehicle the car and that $7000 went
towards the truck so it got us 10 $7,000
cheaper you got a seventh you got $7,000
credit for a $24,000 car yes how is it
possible mmm
we were we've been upside down a lot on
our I thought you paid off the car you
told me you paid off the $24,000 car yes
we did so it's sitting there was zero
debt and it's worth $24,000 right I
would assume so yes and we only got
7,000 when we gave it to them
I was it possible that you would give
someone a $24,000 car for $7,000 are you
are you a charitable organization no we
were just stupid yeah
like lots of stupid not just a little I
don't believe this story there's
something wrong I think you got your
numbers screwed up nobody could do what
you've done that just is not possible
okay
so here's the situation today today you
have a bunch of debt and you're
obviously completely freaking out of
control and you've just discovered our
stuff you do not need to buy a house
under any circumstances right now you
are not under control you can't even
figure out what happened to the $24,000
from your car so you guys have got to
get your head around how money works
where it is it's gonna take you little
time to do this take your time and slow
down and quit buying crap stop it stay
off the car lot you're obviously a
target there you probably need to sell a
stupid truck I can't tell I can tell
what's going on here but you probably
need to sell the truck and get down into
a little cheaper car and let's get that
debt cleaned up but in the meantime
before you make that decision slow down
let's get everything wrapped get our
head wrapped around these numbers a
little bit better when you're not on the
radio and nervous and all of that
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up we're
gonna put you in Financial Peace
University and see if we can walk you
through getting your arms around this
stuff you and your husband and both of
you need to know your numbers and both
of you need to slow down this impulsive
herky-jerky way of doing things is
killing you it's killing you thanks for
the call hopefully we can help you turn
this around